die weltverbesserer mit globetrotter im
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wartet seit über 40 jahren global um die
punkte sind für menschen dar denen es
weniger gut geht
sie handeln wenn andere noch regen
sie machen die welt zu einem besseren
ort
sie sind
die weltverbesserer
[Musik]
die junge ärztin melanie holz kann muss
in einem äthiopischen spital die
unfallchirurgie übernehmen
[Musik]
nach der abreise ihres kollegen ist sie
nun auf sich gestellt
der schweizer chefarzt jörg pelzer hat
eben dieses spital mit seiner stiftung
aufgebaut
bald wird er melanie holz kam tatkräftig
unterstützen man jetzt neue witsch ist
da für flüchtlinge auf der balkanroute
gemeinsam mit ihrem team hilft sie einer
syrischen familie mit drei behinderten
kindern
manuel bauer ist hoffotograf des
tibetischen geistigen oberhaupt des
dalai lama im abgelegensten winkel
niemals will er das dorf samt song das
vom klimawandel bedroht ist an einem
besseren ort neu aufbauen bereits waren
baumaschinen vor
aber die landfrage ist noch ungeklärt
wir sind im dorf sant joan in ehemaligen
königreich muss dann das heute zu nepal
gehört manuel bauer und sein übersetzer
c fango sind unterwegs um den jüngsten
dorfbewohner kennen zu lernen
von kathmandu aus reiste manuel bauer
über jobs am nachmittag über das
städtchen lohmann tang erreichte er
seinem song auf 4000 metern höhe
wie heißt das baby
seit kurzem zählt samsung 85 einwohner
tsering denn du bist zur welt gekommen
seine mutter ssangyong ist stolz auf
ihren jungen die geburt vor fünf wochen
war schwierig fast wäre sie gestorben
der fotograf sascha moll das letzte mal
vor einem jahr
die schlachte stimmige musik wie sie zu
stellen
es ist doch nur klopp er ist etwas von
yvonne meiner frau sie war vor einem
jahr hier dank ein geschenk sofort
auszupacken gilt hier als unhöflich und
gierig lang nur lässt sich darum nur die
karte vorlesen zur schule gehen konnte
sich hier oben nur für kurze zeit
[Musik]
alles liebe und gute für dich von yvonne
salons mutter ist 57
sie hat die ehe zwischen ihrer tochter
und wann die arrangiert wie das so
üblich ist wann wie kommt das momentan
wohl die klosterschule besucht
das junge paar freut sich dass das neue
dorf nicht mehr so abgelegen ist ich
hoffe dass mein sohn am neuen ort zur
schule gehen kann und eine ausbildung
bekommt es ist gut dass er dann eher bei
momentan ist
[Musik]
ich will zurück nach rom
wir hatten viele probleme hier wegen der
regenzeit aber auch wenn jemand krank
wird
hier gibt es keinen arzt und auch keine
mönche für religiöse feste kommt
zunächst es ja wieder
ja denn bringst du dann die babyfotos
mit mach ich ja
[Musik]
china ist mit 200.000 einwohnern eine
der größten städte im westen äthiopiens
von der äthiopischen hauptstadt addis
abeba ist immer 350 kilometer entfernt
[Musik]
die ärztin melanie holzkern arbeitet
hierfür zwei monate auf der
unfallchirurgie der universitätsklinik
sieht dies als freiwillige und
unentgeltliche
die unfallchirurgie kann maximal 60
patienten aufnehmen
die warteliste ist lang jede entlassung
ist eine erleichterung für ihre
patienten hat die ärztin immer
süßigkeiten dabei sie will auch karamell
die trostpflästerchen kommen an um den
bruch vom ellbogen com net org machen
chirurg michael schmelz war ihr
vorgänger jörg peter peltzer ist der
gründer des projekts
beide stehen ihr bei über 10.000
kilometer hinweg
hallo hier bin ich habe eine frage ist
heute einkommen oder gestern nacht und
als gesehen diese firma faktor dar
gemeinsam findet man eine lösung die
medizinische versorgung im land ist
katastrophal
dieses spital hat ein einzugsgebiet von
zehn millionen menschen
die sprechstunde ist immer überfall wie
läuft es ist gebrochen was für einen
bruch ein knochen haarriss wie lange
schon ein monat einen mord
oft fehlen aktuelle röntgenbilder für
eine operation bezahlt ein patient 30
franken ein durchschnittliches
monatseinkommen
meist müssen dafür mehrere familien
zusammen liegen in der serbischen
grenzstadt peschawar muss man jetzt neue
wird eine frau abweisen sie sucht einen
job aber waren ja arbeitet hier fast nur
mit freiwilligen branche wo ist ein
serbisches städtchen an der grenze zu
mazedonien
dort hilft waren ja seit vier monaten
flüchtlingen auf der balkanroute
[Musik]
diese menschen aus syrien afghanistan
und irak warten auf den zug der sie an
die serbisch kroatischen grenze bringen
soll
sie warten seit acht stunden auch die
syrische familie mit den fünf kindern
will so bald als möglich weiterreisen
ihr ziel ist deutschland das die
flüchtlinge damals noch willkommen hieß
wanja kümmert sich um sie sind alle da
drei der fünf kinder der familie sind
behindert und sitzen im rollstuhl
die strapazen der reise sind kaum
vorstellbar wollen wir hier warten er
saß mir die polizei gesagt die volontäre
der boarder free association sind
angespannt
denn bei der einfahrt des zuges kommt es
oft zu chaotischen szenen der alle
flüchtlinge einen platz ergattern wollen
[Musik]
dann endlich der zug fährt ein
wir haben ein kind im rollstuhl können
wir durch es gibt platz für alle egal
gemeinsam packen die volontäre an bis
sie drei kinder mit den rollstühlen
sicher im zug sind kein einfaches
unterfangen kann sie mir helfen
die beiden haben keinen platz
wir müssen um platzieren dort hat es
plätze gut aber wir sagten die mutter
soll mit den beiden hier bleiben für 350
menschen geht die reise weiter über 1000
kilometer durch ganz serbien bis nach
china an die kroatische grenze
[Musik]
ein neuer tag im nepalesischen dorf samt
das ganze dorf soll umgesiedelt werden
der klimawandel verunmögliche das
weiterleben hier sagt manuel bauer noch
einmal besucht er zámbó und wann die er
zeigt ihnen die ausgabe des magazins des
tages-anzeigers den er um spenden für
den dorf neubau geworben hat sammer
erkennt sich wird verliehen
und hier steht
bitte helft und spendet geld für das
bau- und viele schweizer haben das
gelesen und geld gespendet
es fehlt also mir hand es ist 30 franken
sie das holz kostet und also deshalb ist
übersichtlich frankreich 7 gesuchten am
landweg weit übers ziel geschossen und
das gibt mir die möglichkeit der
wichtige prozess wieder zu unterstützen
und nicht bewusst stieg und so große
verantwortung dass spenden das geld sie
im fond lizenzen und jetzt nicht einfach
das dorf zu vergolden
sowohl für yvonne und mich manuell
erhält nun seinerseits ein geschenk von
sammel danke vielmals danke
in der äthiopischen stadt immer herrscht
auf der unfallchirurgie hochbetrieb
seit dem morgen wartet melanie holz gang
auf einen freien operationstisch ich
frage nur gibt es keinen anderen nein es
gibt wirklich keinen anderen
das ist also der einzige ja so ist es
jetzt halt eben
ja aber meine patienten müssen noch
länger warten
ja aber wenn es ein notfall ist ich
verstehe kein problem ich wollte es mir
wissen
zwei tische sind für die frauen besetzt
kein problem
notfälle anderer stationen werfen
melanies planung über den haufen
ja ich weiß wir sind keine freunde mehr
ja ein notfall aber meine patienten
warten doch auch schon am frühen morgen
habe ich versucht ich habe deine planung
gesehen aber dann für die muttern zu
bluten
es ist ein notfall ich verstehe das
danke kein problem
so hilft melanie eben bei der
improvisierten sprechstunde mit warum
funktioniert das nicht mit den pferden
viele patienten kommen um die fäden
ziehen zu lassen aber niemand
das kind das von einem motorrad
angefahren wurde konnte noch immer nicht
operiert werden
für einmal hat melanie holz gang viel
zeit sich vorzubereiten
[Musik]
mit jedem patienten der nicht operiert
werden kann steigt der druck dann
endlich wird ein operationsteam für das
dreijährige kind frei opfer von
verkehrsunfällen sind hier häufiger
patienten
[Musik]
spürst du den bruch hier die 33-jährige
chirurgin leitet die assistenzärzte an
sie ist gefordert das konzept im kopf
[Musik]
zwei operationen und einige stunden
später macht melanie holzkern feierabend
die aufgeschobenen eingriffe bedeuten
für morgen noch mehr arbeit
[Musik]
solange noch aus um 9 uhr ist nachtruhe
im spital delsberg macht auch chefarzt
york pelzer feierabend
er hat vor zehn jahren die
unfallchirurgie in china eröffnet und
später die stiftung schweizer chirurgen
in äthiopien gegründet
dreimal im jahr besucht er sein baby wie
er sein projekt net morgen ist es wieder
soweit
afrika und immer immer schön wetter
arbeitskosten segels display des wieder
gold wert war
darunter sind das er bereits von der
schweiz tollen job machen zum glück aus
die macher stolz machen
in der serbischen grenzstadt peshawar
ist waren ja zu neuem schmidt volontärin
anna friedlich auf der suche nach einer
besseren unterkunft für ihre
freiwilligen team
in diesem haus lebte waren ja schon im
sommer 2015 als sie mit 2000 franken
spenden geld im rucksack hierher kam um
zu helfen
[Musik]
das zelt von wurde free association ist
nur eine knappe viertelstunde zu fuß
entfernt hier hauten zuvor freie
volontäre die keine organisation
angehört
die häuser sind ein glücksfall
zusammen bezahlt waren das verein dafür
umgerechnet 430 franken miete im monat
a
[Musik]
manuel bauer und silvan haben einen
vierstündigen fußmarsch hinter sich sie
erreichen das bauland dass der ehemalige
könig von mustang den einwohnern von
samsung geschenkt hat
[Musik]
bereits wird das bauholz für die neuen
häuser geliefert
es kommt aus den tiefer gelegenen wälder
nepals mandlbauer bezahlt es mit
spendengeldern der magazin reportage
[Musik]
lasst uns auf den hügel gehen helfen
sagt neubauer sei der sinn des lebens
aber es bedeutet auch eine große
verantwortung
[Musik]
hier ein neues dorf zu bauen widerstrebt
dem fotografen
es sei riskant sagt er aber für die
beiden anderen bauplätze gibt es keine
bewilligung
die landfrage ist ungeklärt dessen
ungeachtet vermessen ingenieure aus
kathmandu die zukünftigen felder
organisiert hat sila manawan manuel
barros freund und wichtigster mann vor
ort
wir müssen das land vor erdrutschen
schützen und herausfinden wie das wasser
auf verschiedenen ebenen zu den feldern
gelangt der bewegungs kanal aus
verschwunden
er wurde von einem erdrutsch zerstört
manuel bauer fühlt sich machtlos und
ausgeliefert
lokal auf das so ich meine ich finde es
unmöglich
aber ich fragen was vorstellen dass das
da bis jetzt auch noch kann hp zahlt
verrückt ist wohl nicht gesehen oder und
das er zuvor bricht das ist für mich
machen abnehm auf die anders so vorwärts
und wer weiß wo problem sind und uns
passiert wirklich lacht übers telefon
versucht la mama wann auf die tal
gemeinschaft die über die anderen
bauplätze entscheidet druck auszuüben
er will einer definitiven lösung jetzt
ich habe ihm gesagt dass ich nicht
länger warten kann
ich musste ingenieure bezahlen die
arbeiter bis morgen müssen sie mir sagen
ja es ist unklar
ja das glaube ich nicht ich kann es auch
auf die harte tour machen
ich warte noch drei vier tage dann lasse
ich die bulldozer auf haben mit
waffengewalt geht sie nicht dann lasse
ich das land eben das wäre die harte
tour
vielleicht sollten wir die kleider
tauschen manchmal bin ich mehr manche
als du wenn es hilft das machen wir das
wenn die einwohner von samsung so zu
lang kommen
[Musik]
frühmorgens im gym melanie holz gang
macht sport und den kopf frei zu kriegen
dass sie dabei für aufsehen sorgt nimmt
sie gelassen grenzen ausloten und neues
kennenlernen
das treibe sie an sagt die 33 jährige
sie rennen nicht mit den beinen
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit herrscht im neu
gebauten gästehaus hochbetrieb
es soll ein rückzugsort für gastierten
sein
der schweizer milliardär hansjörg wyss
hat 150000 franken dafür gespendet
es wurde teurer noch fehlen 200000
franken
mit solchen überraschungen muss man hier
rechte dann ist er da jörg pfälzer ohne
den ist alles hier nicht gäbe
der chefarzt aus delsberg engagiert sich
hier seit 13 jahren das haus scheint
perfekt aber beim näheren hinschauen
zeigen sich grobe mängel auf dass bambus
parkett tropft wasser
[Musik]
die kleine fahrer sind und wo schon
sicheren abschluss fotoschule nicht
funktioniert und gestern waka waka
internen auf gesehen und eine nacht ins
wasser und entsetzte zu beschränkt und
druck haben aber alles kein problem
der 51 jährige legt gleich selber hand
an
seit fast 20 jahren ist jörg pelzer mit
äthiopien verbunden so schnell bringt
ihn nicht aus der fassung
[Musik]
im serbischen grenzstädtchen presse wo
ist für einen moment ruhe eingekehrt
aber waren ja zur neuen die gründerin
der boarder free association hat alle
hände voll zu tun
gestern reisten 350 flüchtlinge weiter
jetzt ist der moment gekommen um
aufzuhören wolldecken müssen gereinigt
werden der schlaf und container und das
zählt alles was waren ja mit ihrem
verein aufgebaut hat wird geschrubbt
[Musik]
in brescia wohlleben 18.000 menschen
fast ausschließlich albanische muslime
80 prozent sind arbeitslos
die meisten männer haben in deutschland
und in der schweiz gearbeitet und sind
dann wieder in ihre heimat zurückgekehrt
im nahe gelegenen supermarkt wollen bahn
ja zur neue witsch und samir chalabi
lebensmittel für die flüchtlinge
besorgen
am meisten brauchen mit zucken weswegen
themen wie viel zucker und mitkochen
jeder tag ist ein winziger gewinnzahlen
nachsehen und wagen sind und das gold
besseres john war also das ist
begeistert denn am rande sachen die
werden wir also händlers seife den
löffel also sonst zocken mit gebucht und
besseren lockt es ist günstiger so einen
kasten wirklich die günstigste mudra
wissen braucht diesen tag aber so spart
man sich das vor allem kinder mann der
in banane zu kriegen
[Musik]
dass sich das investitionsmittel denn
wenn viele putts und auch den boden in
der kaufkraftparität kaufen konnten
wenn man in diesen so ziert er ist
stinkt zum zweiten mann krankheit der
verbreiter bin meistens in serie die
sache liegt und dann weisen eher weil
welche krankheit unterwegs und komisches
beste tag wie geht's meine liebe gut und
wie geht es hier
ich bin wieder hier wir haben noch
bananen und mandarinen bestellt ja das
stimmt alles da drüben
schmolz
damjanovic kaufte waren im wert von
umgerechnet 700 franken ein
das ist kein zuständen spendenkonten den
geldtaschen durch das ist vielleicht bis
zum 19
[Musik]
in muss dann gehen derweil die
vorbereitungsarbeiten für das neue dorf
weiter
die bewohner von samsung sollen hier ein
neues zuhause finden
sie müssen ihr dorf verlassen weil das
wasser auszugehen droht für ihre neuen
häuser stellen die lehmziegel her
auch wann die er vor kurzem vater
geworden ist hilft mit hier ist das
leben gut wenn ich für ein paar tage in
der nähe von lohmann tang bin und dann
nach samsung zurückkehre dann merke ich
dass es hier besser ist als in samsun
manuel bauer hält diese szenen mit der
kamera fest als fotograf dokumentiert er
die fortschritte und hält die spender
auf dem laufenden
bevor regen und kälte einsetzen müssen
die lehmziegel fertig sein
manuel bauer bestand auf der
traditionellen bauweise
auch die frauen helfen tatkräftig mit
für uns ist die arbeit nicht anstrengend
aber für euch diese probleme wissen noch
nicht mal wo anne mit denen häuser und
siegfried manuel bauer muss in die
schweiz zurückkehren
ein ungutes gefühl reist mit denn die
bauland frage ist noch immer ungeklärt
in diesem haus wohnt waren ja zum neuen
beach wenn sie in presse wo ist meistens
bleibt sie für zwei wochen im monat ihr
verein bode free association hat diese
möblierte wohnung für sie gemietet für
200 franken monatlich
sie ist studium rückzugsort geworden
heute sonntag können sie sich eine
atempause von der anstrengenden arbeit
dass ich mich besser kapoor bereit dafür
auch einfach eine kleine clubs läuft und
regelmäßig ist ist man sehr schnell sehr
schnell und ich brauche einfach immer so
samir chalabi soll die arabisch
beibringen wieso nicht so sprechen
man gewöhnt sich dran wie soll ich das
sagen im alltag reden sie sehr
bürokratisch und spricht perfekt
arabisch verschiedene ihr zehnjähriger
sohn lebt bei ihrer mutter in churwalden
was macht ein bisschen großmutter
ich liebe dich ich bin schon traurig
aber ich weiß ist ein echter fan bin und
dann machen wir das mitmachen freut man
sich rufen an
wenn ich dir zeit wo man miteinander
verbringt auch sehr intensiv denn hier
wirklich zwei wochen tag und nacht mit
ihm schlafen zu deinem gleiche arbeit
wenn ihn in in der schweiz finden das
ist viel wert
[Musik]
manuel bauer ist auf der rückreise in
die schweiz
die ungeklärte situation mit dem bauland
beschäftigt ihn
[Musik]
ich bin soeben eingetroffen
ich habe noch nicht mal die hände
gewaschen hast du neuigkeiten
es wird also ein weiteres treffen geben
es tut mir so leid
ich drücke die daumen und hoffe dass es
bald ist
[Musik]
wie geht es weiter
wird das neue dorf überhaupt je gebaut
werden können
zweifel begleiten manuell auf seinem
heimweg die unfallchirurgische abteilung
in china bekommt unterstützung york
pelzer ist für ein paar tage dar und
greift seiner ehemaligen assistenzärztin
melanie holz gang unter die arme beim
ersten gemeinsamen rundgang entdeckten
die beiden ein kind das in lebensgefahr
schwebt mit verletztem arm liegt es seit
stunden in der notfallaufnahme der
schamane im dorf band ihm den arm viel
zu stark ab die verzweifelten eltern
brachten das kind schließlich den
zwölfstündigen weg hierher ein stapel
holz ist dass das kind gefallen
er ist wohl gebrochen
ich denke
das müssen wir heute meint mit dem gast
mit dem täter muss 100 entwickler wird
also da muss man ein notfall meist
spalte schon mal probiert rolltreppe und
wenn sich ausprobieren am leben zu
halten
orf.at wie zweitwagen dass er versuchen
den an zu retten
in der nächsten folge die beiden ärzte
geben alles um das kind zu retten
aber das leben der neunjährigen wird
danach nie mehr so sein wie vorher
manja zum neue macht einen ausflug mit
ihrem sohn und verlagert ihre hilfe nach
griechenland dort gerät sie in eine
kritische situation und ein großer
moment für manuel bauer die landfrage
ist gelöst
das neue dorf wird gebaut
[Musik]
die welt verbessern mit globetrotter um
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
weltweit sind über 40 jahre globetrotter
punkt ch